have you ever wondered what the world's
most successful billionaires have in
common besides their massive bank
accounts and private jets it's not just
good genes or dumb luck these people
have developed powerful habits that have
helped them achieve incredible success
and become some of the most influential
people on the planet in this episode
we'll dive into the fascinating world of
billionaire habits and uncover mindset
hacks specific routines and thinking
patterns that have helped people like
Warren Buffett Jeff Bezos and Elon Musk
make their fortunes and change the world
so whether you're looking to become the
next big thing in Tech Media or fashion
or just want to learn from the best this
episode is for you so grab your favorite
beverage put on your billionaire mindset
and get ready to uncover the habits of
highly successful billionaires enjoy
habit number one is never stop learning
with Warren Buffett I'm wondering what
habit or habits have contributed most to
your ability to continue learning and
improving your investment decisions in a
changing business and financial
environment
I would say that
at least in my case I haven't been
continually learning in terms of the
basic principles
you always learn a little more about
given techniques or we learn you know I
learn more about some Industries over
time and therefore maybe I've widened
the universe in which I can operate all
the more funds narrows it back down
unfortunately but
I know more about businesses than I knew
20 years ago or 40 years ago
I haven't really changed the principles
the last
change the basic principles are still
Ben Graham
they were affected in a significant Way
by Charlie and Bill Fisher in terms of
looking at the better businesses but
they but I didn't leave any of I didn't
leave Graham behind on that and I really
haven't learned any
any new fundamental principles but I may
have learned a little bit more about
how business operates over time
and there's really nothing I mean you
ought to you ought to get a investment
framework that comes straight from in My
View From the intelligent investor and
from Phil Fisher uh more from the
intelligent investor actually and then I
think you ought to learn everything you
can about
Industries and businesses that where you
think you have the ability to get your
mind around them if you work at them and
and with that Arsenal you'll do very
well and if if you've got the
temperament for the business habit
number two is have a beginner's mind
with Jeff Bezos one of the great
paradoxes of inventing at a high level
is that you need to be an expert in your
domain area
and you need to have a beginner's mind
you absolutely need both of those things
the world is too complex to actually
just be a beginner so you know I can't
no matter how inventive I am I can't go
invent a new kind of brain surgery
you have to be a neurosurgeon you have
to already know all there is to know
about brain surgery and then take it to
the next level the problem is for many
people by the time they become true
experts they've lost that ability to see
things in a fresh way they've lost The
Beginner's mind
and so that's another thing you always
need to be stepping back and saying if I
I'm an expert I'm an expert in launch
vehicles or whatever it is
I I need to step back and say okay
if I were looking at this for the first
time what would I be seeing and noticing
these are just some of the things you
need to do to be Innovative habit number
three is look for negative feedback with
Elon Musk it's very important to to seek
out to actively seek out and listen very
carefully to negative feedback
and this is something that people tend
to avoid because it's it's painful yeah
um but but I think this is a very common
mistake is to to not actively seek out
and listen to
uh negative feedback what do you do that
you go into forums do you go into
Twitter like what are your areas where
you go to look for feedback on let's say
the Tesla well it's like everyone I talk
to is um in fact when um when friends
get a product I say look don't tell me
what you like tell me what you don't
like right
um and and because otherwise your friend
is not going to tell you what he doesn't
like right this guy's gonna say oh I
love this and that and and then and
leave out the this is the stuff I don't
like list because he wants to be a
friend one you know it doesn't want to
offend you so um
so you really need to
[Music]
to to to sort of coax negative feedback
um and you should you know that if
somebody is your is your friend or at
least not your enemy and they're giving
you negative feedback
um then they may be wrong but it's
coming from a good place
um and sometimes even your enemies give
you good negative feedback also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there habit number four is stay ahead
with Mark Cuban how do you identify
what's next
you know I I just read a lot right I'm
just one of those guys that just
consumes information on the Internet or
where everything yeah everything
anywhere I can get I just try to learn
you've always been this way yeah yeah
I've always been like a knowledge geek
where it mostly Tech but it could be
anything not just anything business
related technology related marketing
related you know um culture related I
want to try to stay on top of it you
know Steve Steve Jobs had this this one
quote that really stuck with me he said
everything's a remix and if you look at
the early days of the Apple products
there was this company back in the day
called Xerox Park and Xerox came out
with the first Mouse driven PC
but their marketing sucked and they had
no idea what they were doing no one knew
what they're about Steve Jobs gave me a
little bit of this a little bit remixed
and Bam right all of a sudden you got
apple and then a Macintosh and then
they're yeah he made it sexier yeah and
then even he got fired right he got
fired from that company and then they
had to bring him back to make it work
and so you know for me the more you
learn the more you know how to remix and
that's what this is all about so you
know how do you go from YouTube which
was the first platform for video that
got big to Instagram to Snapchat and
know okay do I want to be on Discover do
I want to be on reels do I want to be on
Tick Tock you know and if I do this you
know how's YouTube going to treat me and
all the decisions you guys you guys have
got to make on a daily basis you know
and the fact that like we're just
talking you created all these products
and you wanted to be organic that's a
business decision too and then you have
to learn by trial and error right you
were curious about what might work you
know obviously you know you're walking
proof of what does work right and now
you've got to be able to continue to
make those decisions because in this
business with all the margins on these
projects everybody's coming at you all
the time right yeah and they think they
can do the exact same thing but it's not
that easy but for me it's like that's
why I try to stay ahead because whether
it's artificial intelligence whether
it's VR whether it's crypto whether it's
metaverse all these things may not be
prime time yet but I want to know when
they will be and I want to be out front
when they when they are habit number
five is don't give up too early with Sam
Altman knowing when to quit and knowing
when to give up on something is
there's no perfect answer to that but
it's really challenging to even get that
approximately correct I think most
people give up on things way too early
so the mistake that most people make is
they try something it does not
immediately work you see this
particularly in young entrepreneurs it
does not immediately work after seven
weeks they say you know what I tried
this thing it's just not meant to be and
I have too many other projects and so
they immediately give up and you kind of
you know the satirical version of this
is people that are 23 and have started
14 startups because they give up on
everyone before it could ever possibly
be successful these things are really
hard
um they take a very long time there are
a lot of critics there are a lot of
people who say this thing sucks it's
gonna fail it's really stupid and then
also there's like
what at YC we call the trough of sorrow
where no one even bothers to say it
sucks because no one cares at all
um and that is at least as demotivating
uh most of the founders that I have
spent a lot of time with that have gone
on to be super successful spent a very
long time on their idea uh when a lot of
other people would have given up and
either people said it sucks or people
said nothing at all and
a framework that I have for when to go
up and when to keep working is it should
be an internal not an external decision
if people aren't using it or if people
are saying it's bad that alone is not a
reason to give up you want to pay some
attention to that they might be right
um but
I think the best entrepreneurs I know
they make an internal decision about
when to give up or when to keep working
on something it's basically when you
have run out of ideas and something is
not working then it's a good time to
stop habit number six is meditate with
Ray dalio how long have you been
meditating for actually 42 years
and what got you started the Beatles
When The Beatles started meditating and
um I they drew attention to it and it
was a uh curiosity and I thought I would
try it and then
um it's changed my life it's uh the big
the biggest uh influence in whatever
success I've had in life so can you
remember what it was like in the first
few weeks or the first few months yeah I
remember wrestling around with it I
remember that uh you know you go into
the Mantra I went into the Mantra then
the thoughts would come back and it
would be that back and forth and then as
it got better and better and I got
deeper into it the thoughts would become
more valuable more tantalizing and it
was almost
um you know more of a temptation to
think about those particular thoughts
because I didn't want to lose those
ideas and then I knew that I had to push
those away and it was almost difficult
and then after a while while I remember
them disappearing into it and that was
something the first benefits were that
ability that they have the quietness the
Tranquility
um the ability to get energy from it
rather than sleep it would provide me
more energy than sleeping
um those kinds of benefits but then it
went on
to develop an ongoing Equanimity that
that centeredness that ability to go
above myself and my circumstances and to
look down at them from a higher level
with a Clarity and an objectivity and
then it started to bring out my
subconscious and my creativity because
subsequently I've studied Neuroscience
I've been very interested in that and
and I've learned that there's a part of
our brain in the neocortex which is
where imagination exists which is where
creativity exists and it opened me to
that I experienced it I didn't
understand what was happening at the
time but it provided those things as
time went on and habit number seven the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is keep a journal with Oprah
Winfrey as I've grown older I to
appreciate
appreciate you do too I've asked I'm
asking this graduating class those of
you here I've asked all of my viewers in
America and across the world to do this
one thing keep a grateful Journal
every night list five things that
happened this day
in days to come that you are grateful
for what it will begin to do is to
change your perspective of your day and
your life I believe that if you can
learn to focus on what you have you will
always see that the universe is abundant
and you will have more if you
concentrate and focus in your life on
what you don't have you will never have
enough be grateful keep a journal
stop trying to do this alone
if you've got a big idea inside you you
can't do this alone you need people
around you to help you to encourage you
to support you to cover your weaknesses
to help you actually go off and
accomplish that big dream of yours
this is one of the biggest things that I
think holds people back holds
entrepreneurs back
is you're probably decently good at the
thing that you want to do
you know you've had some experience or
you've gone and learned and figured it
out and you still to get better as you
keep practicing and keep going and doing
more and maybe at some point you even
did try to hire somebody maybe at some
point you did try to bring somebody on
and it didn't work out
didn't work out
and here's where everybody makes the
mistake you Retreat and go back to say
you know what it was just a lot faster
when I did it myself does that happen
has that happened to you ever been there
you hired somebody you thought I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna hire somebody you do
it it doesn't work out
and then you go back to say I'm just
going to do this all myself no no no no
no no no that is not the answer
that is not the answer that's like if
you go on one date and it doesn't work
out now you're never going to go on
another date again you're never going to
be married
right that doesn't make sense
that doesn't make sense you're living in
fear as opposed to actually trying to
build the thing that you're capable of
building
here's what happens
when you first hire somebody you know
what you're doing
right it's like when you first did
anything you don't know what you're
doing
so why do you expect to be great at
picking the right person and then
treating them well then managing them
well you don't know what you're doing uh
there's a guy in my Movie Makers who
joined my Discord as well
and he was talking about how he had
hired his second video editor and it
didn't work out
and he had to let the person go so he's
hired two video editors both of them
couldn't get his style
and he had to let them go and he's going
back to editing everything himself now
as a short-term solution great like
stuff has to get up videos have to be
edited get them out
but don't stop searching
just because you had two failed hires
right like if you
tomorrow are editing videos awesome but
if you next year are still editing your
videos not awesome nope not awesome not
anymore right this is how we start to
raise our standards
and so the first two people that you
hired weren't good fits great keep
searching keep looking
your perfect fit is out there and as you
go through some people and go through
the process
you'll get better at actually finding
the right person
you know you'll get better at it don't
judge yourself that say well I suck at
this I can't hire I'm never gonna find
the person it's just faster to do it
myself right there's that old expression
you can go fast by yourself but you go
far with the team
you have to build a team so let's talk
about how to do it okay let's stop let's
talk about steps practical steps
building the team creating the culture
uh someone who now has 37 people on the
team I'm not I'm not Jeff Bezos with uh
I don't know how many thousands of
people are on his team but 37 on our
team right now how do you how do you go
from starting up to that step number one
is figure out what is the most important
skill that you need that has to get done
in the business that you suck at
okay and you don't want to get better at
what do you suck at that has to get done
in the business not something that you
know maybe it's a nice to have it like
it has to get done in the business you
suck at it and not just you suck at it
right now you just you never want to get
better at it you're just not interested
in it some people love this thing and
you hate it and you never want to get
better at it what is that thing
that's the first person you need to
bring on into your business it could be
part-time it it I it definitely should
not be a full-time person
here's why
one you don't know how to hire yet
two it's going to take you too long to
be able to save up the money to hire
somebody full-time and three you're not
used to managing people
so you want a part-time person when I
first started I had interns I had
interns from high school who were
helping me do a lot of the things that I
need to get done and it was part of
their school credit Nina is back
um I did foreign language interns so
people came to Toronto as part of their
education
being from a different country learning
English and getting job experience
and find people I've had people
volunteer to join I've had people work
one hour a day to join right just like
you need to start getting some people
involved because
it makes you feel like you're not alone
doing this which is a big deal and it
also starts building some traction you
know starts finally getting some of the
things off your plate that you wish
didn't exist anymore and suddenly now
they don't because somebody else is
taking care of it right
step number two is you have to start
asking for help this is a big problem
for a lot of entrepreneurs you're afraid
to ask for help at the startup
phase especially
awesome what if they steal my idea it's
one of the most common questions we ever
felt that what if what if I tell
somebody my idea and they steal it they
go with it
well it's possible
it's possible very low possibility most
people are are running their own
business the amount of people have come
to me and say Evan uh I'd love your help
on this but but I need you to sign this
NDA non-disclosure agreement it's like I
don't care about your idea
I have my own business to run I've got
my own channels my own team my own
things to worry about I'm not gonna they
think the top priority is you have some
great idea that I'm going to then take
and run with that that's now my new
business plan no and now you missed the
chance to actually get some feedback and
help
so you have to share your ID the idea
alone is not enough it's the execution
that really matters
so it's not just the idea that you've
got is can you be the one to go off and
create it to make it to to birth it to
turn it into reality and speed matters
have you ever seen anybody with your
idea right air quotes your idea
go off and win while you were still
sitting on the sidelines
right that seen it happen so many times
have so many people message me about it
it's like I had this idea three years
ago and I didn't do it and now here's
this person off making millions off of
it well what's the difference chances
are they had less heart than you less
less
of a drive to do good less caring than
you so why are they winning well because
they started and they asked for help
and you were trying to do it all by
yourself
so you have to share your idea you have
to recruit people on board you have to
ask for help because those people can
make the difference between you actually
following through
on your goals
I then step three is you have to Mentor
the people on your team you have to care
about them as humans the next big
mistake a lot of entrepreneurs make when
they're when they're hiring is okay this
person's gonna come on they're going to
take all the stuff off my plate so I can
focus on being the CEO and then
everything's gonna be great
and that's a nice Theory
um you know that that
kind of happens but what you want to
think about is
this is a human working with you
you know this is a human who's got goals
and their own Ambitions and their own
dreams and your job should be to help
them grow as a human that they should be
better
as a person by spending time with you by
being around you
and by being in your company
most people treat people like robots
they treat them like monkeys okay get
this done get that done perfect gun you
know you made you made my life easier
awesome that's what you're hired to do
go do your job
where where
people make the mistake of is one not
given enough training at the beginning
like did you actually set somebody up
for success and the two just not caring
about them enough as a human
I'm actually starting to find it harder
as I grow it was a lot easier when I had
one to five people on the team but at 37
I don't know what everybody's up to I
don't remember everybody's projects I'm
not in as much of the day-to-day of what
they're doing I find it hard to balance
everybody's
goals and just stay on top of of their
life and I don't know what it's going to
look like when we're at 50 people or 75
people or 100 people I don't know what
that process looks like I'm figuring out
you know what I gotta ask for help as I
grow
but two of the things that I've done
that have worked out pretty well
the first is
I dedicate Mondays to team days
so I have an entire day
of the week that's dedicated to team
and so
I'm spending that day on Zoom calls or
in person meeting with Team asking them
what's going on helping them with their
projects and just spending time with
them and so people know that on Mondays
when they save all their stuff and talk
to me about it
scheduling in time for Team matters
so I have different things for different
days of the week today's a Tuesday
because I'm recording so recording is
Tuesday
but yesterday was Monday and and I was
spending the whole time basically on
Zoom calls with team
the second thing that I'll do is a is a
quarterly check-in with people and we
don't even talk about the business
you should do it on a Sunday so it's not
a work day it's a Sunday morning coffee
every Sunday I'm spending with someone
on my team
so Sunday morning I grab my coffee they
grab whatever drink they want and we do
a session together and we will touch on
business we'll touch on what they're
doing but not operationally focused not
hey you didn't get this thing done or
hey how are we doing on this project
it's more like where do you want to go
with your life
what are you curious about what are you
loving about the work that you're doing
here how can I help you get to the next
step what else are you curious about
what are your other goals just just a
life conversation
and you'd be surprised that
what comes out
and most people all they all they really
need is just somebody to listen to them
and care
and sometimes action happens immediately
after sometimes it happens you know the
next month or the next quarter but when
you know the hopes the goals the dreams
the Ambitions of the people on your team
the people around you it allows you to
be a much better and much more effective
leader
so we took you to this the process of
startup zero you know Team all the way
to now how do you manage you know your
first 37 at least people in your company
but underpinning all of this is
the understanding that you can't do this
alone and one of the things that will
help you to do the work to create the
things that you want in your life
is it will help you if you train your
mind
to start spotting evidence as you're
doing the work as you're going through
your day it will help you if you train
your mind to start scanning the world
and spotting evidence that yes indeed
the world is sending you positive
signals that things are going to work
out now why is it important to train
your mind to help you get what you want
well the reason why is because if you
get into a negative mindset if you start
thinking
this business is never going to work why
even bother I'm never going to meet
anybody it's nothing but losers out
there look at all these idiots on hinge
why the hell should I keep doing this if
you allow your mind to start to rest in
a pessimistic negative protective scared
and doubtful stance your mind will
continue to show you reasons why there's
nobody on hinged worth talking to your
mind will continue to show you all the
reasons why you will never make it in
business your mind will continue to show
you all the reasons why you're never
going to lose that weight and be able to
tuck in your shirt as my friend Corinne
Crabtree always talks about that
transformational moment and when your
mind goes negative your mind starts to
scan the world and will show you more
reasons to stop and the power of
training your mind to spot positive
signs is very simple the power is that
your mind will start to show you reasons
to keep going your mind will help you
take the step your mind will encourage
you to feel optimistic to feel empowered
just like you woke up today on a Tuesday
and it was February 22nd 2022 and those
numbers are lining up and that makes you
in your heart and soul go whoa something
cool could happen today like that
only happens like once in my lifetime
those numbers are going to line up like
that today is a really cool day let's go
do something with this you could create
that kind of attitude every single
freaking day of your life you could if
you train your mind and if you start
taking action and training your mind is
the key piece that we're going to talk
about so for those of you that have read
the high five habit one of the things
that I talk about a lot is every single
day find a naturally occurring
heart-shaped object in the world it
could be a stone it could be a leaf it
could be a cloud it could be a shape in
your coffee hey Chris if we've got
anything around here that looks like a
heart hand it to me and the reason why I
love telling you to start playing a game
with yourself well you start your day
going mind brain show me some heart oh
what is this come here dog treat oh my
God it's a dog treat look at this guys
what shape is that
that right there is a harp
there we go check that out
if you say brain mind show me a heart
today guess what's gonna happen that
damn dog biscuit it's gonna show it's
gonna you're gonna be like there's a
heart you're gonna look out at the sky
and you're gonna see a heart shape oh
right there in the mountains there's a
heart shape in the mountains in southern
Vermont you're going to see it in the
clouds what you're doing when you tell
your mind what's important to you is
you're telling your mind and the filter
in your brain to change in real time and
allow into your consciousness
what's important to you and if you want
to see hearts by God those damn dog
treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train
your mind it's freaking incredible and
if you want to see evidence of this
follow me on social media if you follow
me Mel Robbins on social media you will
see every day I am reposting your
stories of finding heart shapes around
the world now why is this important well
it's important because it's a simple way
to prove to you that your mind changes
in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and
optimistic and encouraging of yourself
if you get serious about saying this I
don't want to see all the reasons why
I'm unhappy I don't want to see
everybody else in the world that's
launched a business or that's lost
weight and is healthy or that has a
really good marriage or relationship and
I don't want to see that and and have my
mind process it as evidence that it's
never going gonna happen for me I want
my mind to reprogram itself and see
other people's businesses and see other
people getting healthy and see other
people in relationships and I want my
mind to say yeah if they can do it I can
do it that's evidence if that person can
get healthy so can I if that person can
find somebody on hinge so can I if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can I other people can become evidence
that you can have it too right now your
mind is so up from your past that
when you see what other people have and
you don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
going to win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what I wanted that sucks
and so what I want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind
to filter the world differently just
like you woke up and you saw the date
today 2 22 22 and your brain saw that
was like whoa this is a once in a
lifetime day everybody
you are never going to have another day
that lines up like this ever
what are you gonna do with this day your
mind already interpreted this as wow
something cool could happen and if you
tell yourself something amazing is going
to happen today
something will because you're going to
be looking for it I swear to God
something will
something will if you want to see the
good all around you you got to tell your
mind you want to see the good and this
just isn't a bunch of horsesh everybody
this isn't toxic positivity there is a
filter in your brain called the
reticular activating system
the reticular activating system I call
it the RAS I like to think about it like
a giant hair net on your head and this
Ras sits over your brain I'm probably
getting this wrong I'm not a
neuroscientist I could give about
getting it right I just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a PhD
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life that's
what I'm here for in your life I'm here
to translate this stuff into simple
believable and actionable things that
you can do to take all this super cool
stuff that people are researching and
apply it to your normal person's
everyday life to help you change from
the inside out and one of the coolest
things that you have at your disposal is
you have a whole system in your body
that you can train and change and one of
those things that you can train and
change that is impacted by that real
that word you're hearing a lot of
neuroplasticity that just means that
things are able to twist and bend and
change and you're able to learn new
things for as long as you're alive as
long as you're breathing everybody you
got a chance to change the way that you
think as long as you are breathing you
got a chance to change from the inside
out how you experience your life as long
as you are still here watching me people
you got a chance to create a new
experience in your life and one of the
things that helps a lot is understanding
that right now all of the bullsh from
your past has jammed the filter in your
mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding
your ability to look at the world around
you and see hearts remember this dog
treat hearts look at that there's a
heart right there when it comes to an
affirmation uh affirmations can be
powerful uh
and for some people they're not
and a lot of people say well you know if
the the affirmation is so powerful how
come I'm not experiencing the effect the
what scientists tell us is the average
human
speaks to themselves consciously or
unconsciously we have thoughts spinning
around in our brain about 60 to 80 000
thoughts per day some of those thoughts
are the words to the songs and they are
the affirmations
uh neuroscientist Andrew nurburg tells
us Newberg is his name I'm sorry and um
in his work that that a single word a
single word has the power to to change
the genes that create stress or relieve
stress in our lives he's telling us that
that something within us has the ability
to shift the very core of our expression
so we know that words are are powerful
the key to a successful affirmation is
that we must communicate with the
subconscious part of our of our mind
number one number two we must
communicate in the language that the
subconscious recognizes
and this is where uh you know you can
say
I had a friend of mine when I was
working in the corporations that had
affirmations all over his office all
over his computer screen they were on
little Post-it notes in the car we would
carpool in you know my Perfect Mate is
manifesting for me now my Perfect Mate
is manifesting for me now that was his
affirmation and I said do you say these
things he goes oh man I say I'm about a
million times a day I said do they work
for you he says Nah
you know these these things don't work
and I said why do you think they don't
work and he said look at me he says I'm
an engineer I'm a slob he said I I wear
the same clothes to work three out of
five days during the week you know and
and the the bottom line by the time he
finished describing himself to me even
he didn't believe that he was worthy of
his Perfect Mate manifesting for him now
so he was saying the words
but he was not there was the the
underlying emotion and what he was
actually feeding into his his system was
counter to what those words were saying
so it's it's not enough to say the words
when we go into our most ancient and
cherished spiritual Traditions those
words are what become the prayers
and for many people I have and I know
you've heard this as well a lot of
people feel that prayer is broken that
the world doesn't work today the way it
worked in biblical times that we have
lost our power and that we have no
ability to communicate with a greater
power with god with the forces around us
uh and it's largely because
the secrets the Deep truth of our
relationship
fundamental physics of our relationship
to our world uh have been minced and
parceled and in many cases deleted from
the texts leaving us with a sense that
we are essentially powerless beings and
if you are powerless then you are a
victim and if you are a victim you need
a savior and that savior is coming to us
on a silver plate in terms of technology
in terms of political leaders I will
save you if you just do these things
and this is why I say I think one of the
most the most powerful acts and the most
radical act we can do is to think for
ourselves uh original thinking based
upon the Deep truth of our relationship
to our bodies and the Earth not based
upon the false assumptions of obsolete
science that permeate our academic world
right now it's one of the reasons I left
Academia it's one of the reasons many of
my colleagues who are in this genre who
are very well respected scientists have
left Academia because they were not
allowed to share with students and in
their writings and their papers what
they had found in their research that
reflects a very different reality now
for me it's it's a uh it's good news
it's a beautiful message of Hope and
possibility uh as a sovereign biological
being
for a system that's based on centralized
power and control it's probably the
worst news they could imagine because it
means we don't need the centralized
power and control I think ultimately
we're all better off by embracing our
own power because it frees us from the
fear of a changing world and we all know
our world my world is changing your
world is changing nor has it ever yeah
faster than we can document it in our
classrooms and textbooks
but the change isn't necessarily bad
until we compare it to what we've known
in the past and this is where the fear
comes in
so the the new discoveries helping us to
understand
we are part of rather than separate from
our world and this is this is where the
affirmations come in so
in I was at the CERN superconducting
super collider in Geneva Switzerland
where the the physics experiments that
are revealing
what happened moments after our universe
began they recreate
the beginning of our universe and then
they're able to document what happened
then to create the laws of physics that
we are experiencing that we're living
under right now
and what they announced in 2012 is that
there is in fact a field
an intelligent field of energy it's a
subtle energy that underlies all of
creation
um before then it was a metaphor or a
lot of people felt like it was a new age
concept you know we are all one
everything is is connected or an
indigenous you know a lot of indigenous
Elders talk about this here's here's
where they got stuck
and I've gone to Scientific conferences
where they'll take their hands and
they'll say oh yeah there's that's
that's no longer controversial there is
a field there's a field out there that
connects all things and their hands go
like this there's a field out there that
connects all things because
subconsciously they're still saying
we're separate from that field right but
here's what the science is showing us
and this this was a game changer for me
uh just a mind blower that every atom
in every molecule and every cell of our
bodies in this very instant so it's not
like it's about to happen it's it's
happening right now every atom is
constantly emerging and collapsing into
that field
and what that says to us is that we are
the field it's not the fields out there
we literally are wrinkles we are
disturbances in this field this this
body
that is held in place by a conscious
awareness as long as I'm breathing on
this Earth
I am a disturbance I'm a localized
Wrinkle in that field and what that
means
is that if I want to bring about change
in my world I don't have to force a
change out there I become that change
and as I have become that change the
field is now reflecting what it is
because I'm part of the field so it's a
subtle but it's a very powerful way a
very different way of thinking you're
not you're not imposing change on the
world around you
you are becoming the change so you're
becoming the abundance you're becoming
uh the love the Gratitude the care
uh the healing you're becoming those
things and that is very different we're
conditioned to ask for them to plead for
them because we're led to feel powerless
in our lives when in fact there are
modalities of ancient prayer that were
edited
from the the religious texts in the
fourth Century by the church they took
they took out the information helping us
to understand this this deep
relationship leaving us powerless and
and affirmations are essentially a a
form of Prayer
our prayer is a form of affirmation
however you want to look at it where we
are communicating and I want to be
really clear it's not about control it's
not about manipulation it's not about
imposing our will it's about
participating
in the way that this field unfolds and
expresses in in our lives and when you
really begin to get that shift
it's it's subtle and it's powerful it's
not making something happen out there
and that means you can't blame
what's out there for your experiences I
I come from a very dysfunctional broken
family and I had to make a choice early
in life
as to whether or not I would and
Community as to whether or not I would
allow that to Define
my my experience to Define my existence
other people around me had the same
experience and they made very different
choices they today continue to blame
their environment their parents their
family their upbringing
for the sad and unfortunate things in
their lives and and that's a path it's
not right wrong good or bad but we have
a choice to make another path
and when we began as a scientist
beginning to understand these
relationships gave me the reason to
think differently
and it also gave me the reason to test
in my life
if those thoughts are really true or not
what works and what doesn't you wanted
to be a professional baseball player
yeah right yeah but then you got an
injury I did similar to me so you never
made it to the big league sort of play
minor league I did yeah and I played
division one college baseball too yeah I
like every guy like you and I talked
about this last time it's always our
injuries that ended our careers I
probably it probably put me into a
premature place where I was going
anyways you aren't going to be in The
Bigs for I wasn't I played enough
baseball with guys who ended up in the
big leagues to know my limitations yeah
so like anything in life things happen
for you not to you that injury happened
for me it certainly didn't seem like it
at the time but it got me out of that
and into something like what we're
talking about now that completely
changed my life so yeah but yeah I want
to be an athlete for sure all my life
all your life that was my mask and then
when it exactly and then when it ended
your identity was like who am I right
yes lost yeah like a lot you and I were
just Thomas before we went on yeah you
know our professional athlete friends
were their career changes I went into a
like anybody like whatever you're your
dream is when the first one ends it
doesn't happen whether that be a
relationship it could be your marriage
it ends it was a dream right or a
business venture or a sport I went into
a pretty good depression and uh and how
old were you at the time 21 22 and I
ended up you know it's because people
always see the after like the house or
whatever houses or whatever the material
things are but I ended up bad man I
ended up to press I ended up moving back
at home with my parents I was living in
the city I remember I was living in this
sleeping in the same bed I grew up in
with the same teddy bear the same
posters I was like going back in time
like six years on back where I was
totally unemployed and uh couldn't find
work didn't have the motivation to get
up and find a job just sort of eating
out of their fridge and laying around
all day so that's where I was many many
years ago after baseball and when you
realize things in your life happen for
you truly especially in hindsight
everybody knows it in hindsight right if
you look back at any disaster tragedy
most people look back five ten years
later that happened for me that was
actually a good thing and so I was
unemployed I couldn't find a job and my
old man my dad was the best dad role
model he could ever have in your life
hard-working man good man it's better
man than me has more Integrity than me
he's the best man I've ever known but
when I was growing up my dad had a
drinking problem and so my dad had
gotten sober recently and he was going
to these meetings and he comes home from
one of his meetings and says there's a
guy at my meeting who can get you a job
that's right down the street in San
Dimas you're going to be working with
kids doesn't pay anything at six bucks
an hour but you're gonna get this damn
job so show up there tomorrow morning 8
A.M ask for Tim so I walked I drive down
there it's a place called McKinley Home
For Boys little did I know that would
alter
my entire life that was the most
significant thing that happened to me
and so I walk in there
I said I'm Ed mylett I'm here for the
job they're like what job I'm like I
don't know just my dad told me to show
up here yeah I need to ask for Tim
they're like
we have no idea who the hell Tim is
what's his last name I said I I don't I
don't know his last name and they're
like so you showed up for a job that you
don't know what it is and you don't know
who it is it's hiring you I'm like
here's what I know he's an alcoholic I'm
like oh dude yeah we know that too and
so they bring me to the guy and he says
uh you're hired let's go like literally
shakes my hand and you're hired and he
introduces me to these eight boys that
were my boys they were seven eight and
nine years old and basically I lived
with these boys these precious boys and
we ended up adding a few more my boys
were all Wards of the Court they were
all molested by Family more parents were
in prison and so they had no family and
so my whole life changed all of a sudden
these became on this 22 year old guy
these guys become my sons wow and I did
holidays with them I did birthdays with
them I lived with them literally in a
home or like a little dorm McKinley is a
massive campus full of children that
have been displaced from their homes
that live in individual like Cottages
like a foster care facility massive
though really yeah all boys
it's in San Dimas here and um wow it
just altered my life man because I I'd
been an athlete had a huge ego had that
mask I wanted to compete I wanted to win
I wanted attention I wanted recognition
first time literally in my life I went
well I I love helping people I love
making a difference and my boys were
just come from horrendous situations and
so just I always say this all the time
and I have those eyes too you have them
I think sometimes kids who grow up with
some dysfunction they just have
different eyes yeah they just have these
eyes that are these boys all were
different but they had that same eyes
they're just like man love me believe in
me you know care about me and I had
those eyes because I grew up in an
alcoholic family and my whole life
changed I just went wow I love I
actually love helping people and being
involved in people's lives I didn't know
that because everything was you're great
you're great you know what it is when
you're an athlete right everything's
about you you're amazing free dinners
free this you're a stud all of a sudden
I wasn't a stud and all of a sudden it
wasn't about me it was about these 10
boys that ended up being 10 of them and
it just altered my life man and so after
that I ran into the financial business
that I ended up in but I would have
completely flunked out of that Financial
business had I not been with my boys for
those years and I was there for two
years two years yeah man like eight
hours a day type of thing or sometimes
more sometimes 16 18. I I think about
I'm not kidding you I think about my
boys and my experience there two of them
are still very close with me uh every
day there's a moment where I reflect on
that it altered me completely like what
I wanted to do I always wanted to be
famous and Rich and successful and now I
just wanted to serve yeah I wanted to
help the little did I find out I could
get rich and famous and all that other
stuff I thought I wanted through serving
people
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for the
seven books that can make you rich check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there these are seven books
that have had a tremendous impact on my
life how I think about business and I
hope they have the same impact on you
now I used to have a ton of books I used
to have walls and walls of books